okay if you watch this channel you know
I love Doctor Who but it can't always
work I've done a number of videos at
this point talking about how some of my
favorite stuff in Doctor Who I've given
my top ten stories for the ninth tenth
and eleventh Doctor once Peter Capaldi
wraps up his run I'll of course do the
12th doctor I am working my way through
older stuff for the classic doctors I
will start doing top ten lists for older
doctors as well but there's something
I've been avoiding doing and maybe it's
time and that is ten worst
Doctor Who stories now I'm not going to
do it for each doctor I'm going to do it
for the modern era which means starting
with Christopher Eccleston the Ninth
Doctor because that is the stuff that I
have seen all of and can be definitive
about and also quick reminder before I
get started I count two partners as one
story so here we go with the week stuff
number ten Father's Day I've ripped on
this episode before I took heat for it
before I'll probably take heat for it
now but I'm sorry guys
I find this episode just falls flat on
so many levels I don't get really where
roses whole thing with her father came
from that felt completely underdeveloped
prior to this episode given how far she
takes it once she has just to try and
save him but the ultimate solution and
what they were gonna have to do to
resolve the problem that was caused by
all this I figured out immediately so it
frustrated me watching all these other
characters take so long to figure it out
the Reapers I didn't find particularly
interesting or scary this was one of
those episodes where Rose as a character
just annoyed me I get what the episode
was going for and I applaud it for that
and for going for a more emotional story
but I'm sorry guys for me this thing
just fell flat number 9 the doctor's
daughter now this is one where I think
the idea of what all of the ideas
because there are a number of them were
pretty much all good they just I think
they try to cram too many things into
one episode they either needed to remove
some of these elements or they needed to
make this a two-parter because we have
the return of Martha we have the whole
thing with Jenny we've got the action
war that's going on between these two
faction and and the whole thing feels
rushed especially given the emotional
impact that the were supposed to feel
for the death of Jenny at the end of the
story it doesn't land it doesn't work it
might have worked at the end of a
two-parter or in a story that could
focus on her a little bit more clearly
and distinctly and not have to be
juggling all this other stuff but
unfortunately the whole thing feels
jumbled it feels rushed feels like
there's too much going on and I'm sorry
the half just look really dumb it's one
of the worst creature designs that new
doctor who has given us number eight
journey to the center of the TARDIS
again an episode with some really good
ideas that it just it doesn't pull
together again there's some misplaced
attempts at going for emotional way
particularly with the brothers and their
whole thing like they're the revelation
with them towards the end like it barely
makes sense and it certainly doesn't
carry emotional weight the the creatures
that were dealing with and once you find
it well once you find out what they are
I don't know if that makes it better or
worse but certainly the the look of them
is kind of odd and not scary at all I
think they really made a mistake showing
the things as clearly as they did
because the more clearly I saw it
tomorrow is like what the no and to have
a story literally resolved by a big
friendly button I mean all the way from
a meta-level that's kind of fun but no
and effectively having no is his memory
and Cara's memory erased at the end of
it so what was the point of any of it
number seven nightmare in silver now
this is my quintessential this should
have been a two-parter episode because
the thing is just it's at a breakneck
pace it doesn't stop it is throwing so
much going on with the cyber controller
and this whole
new breed of Cybermen that we've never
seen before that we barely get any kind
of read on it like the behind the scenes
stuff I get the concept of them is
awesome because the idea is that the
cybus version of the Cybermen that we've
gotten a new Doctor Who up to this at
this point the ones from the alternate
dimension actually merged with the
Mondas Cybermen from the classic era to
create this whole new breed of Cybermen
that is awesome and it's not on the
screen at all and the kit oh god the
kids are insufferable
I hate these two and the whole thing
with Matt Smith being the cyber
controller and the doctor I know it
doesn't it doesn't quite jell I like the
idea of it but for some reason it just
doesn't completely work I think it's
because there's not enough
differentiation in the performance
between one and the other and I get that
the cyber controller is like you know
breaking into aspects of the doctor
who's gonna act like the doctor but he
acting too much like him I I needed a
cleaner break in terms of personality
between the two and it just it wasn't
enough there's just a whole lot of
things that need to be tweaked if this
was never going to work and as presented
it doesn't number six Sleep No More this
is another one that is partially ruined
by just lousy monsters in this case both
in concept and design the look is weird
and not particularly like there's one or
two shots where it looks kind of creepy
but by and large they just look like
foam and they don't look scary and then
the concept as to what they are is
stupid and goofy and it would have been
fine in a campy ER you know type of
episode but it's trying to play it like
it's horror and it's going with the
found-footage motif which and to its
credit that had neither detracted nor
added much it didn't break it the way I
was expecting that sort of first person
angle stuff to break the narrative so yo
that giving worked well enough I'll give
it that much but the story it's telling
is very standard the doctor shows up and
there's creatures
ah but they like I think ultimately it's
what the creatures are and what though I
have both how they look at what the
explanation of them is it just sinks the
whole thing you're left going yep really
really number five the Lazarus
experiment this you know what this one
doesn't even really feel like an episode
of Doctor Who I don't know what it does
feel like but it just it feels like you
know feels like sliders are really weird
episode of the x-files it just it
doesn't it's missing a sense of wonder
it's missing I don't know what it's
missing it just it doesn't feel like
whoo between the idea behind it which is
just an odd one the whole idea that this
monster is locked away inside human DNA
and personally not buying it and now I
have a pretty wide suspension of
disbelief that I'm willing to extend
these shows you know the monster design
itself it's over-the-top the CG does not
what it didn't even really work at the
time it really doesn't work now but the
whole man made himself a must I don't
know man it just feels like something
from any one of a dozen shows that would
have been on in the 90s it's a weak
generic feeling story it's a bad fit
number four Daleks in Manhattan and the
evolution of the Daleks this is another
one some really good ideas in this but
no just no ultimately it's I think it's
the second half that sinks it more than
the first it's it could have maybe
worked although I think the starting
idea of the Daleks had the Empire State
Building built it's it's a weird place
to start from and then you've got the
pig people when that was odd then you've
got the human Dalek you know evolution
which i think is a good idea and there's
some nifty things that they are not
lightly i that they brought the cult of
Skaro back and I like that the Daleks
are in fighting a little bit and this is
the scheming Daleks as opposed to you
know just rolling through with an army
kind of Daleks that we got more you know
in the new era it's this is more than
subversion behind-the-scenes scheming
thinking up new ideas and I liked that
we got that version of Daleks again but
it just it just doesn't pull together
and the the visual look of the human
Dalek hybrid isn't great and the
performance is just hammy as heck and oh
the woman in that Tallulah I think is
the character's name of that her that
accent oh my god
well I'll give this episode credit for I
really love the song mind you'll put the
devil in me you gotta get the soundtrack
version up and give it a listen it's
awesome but that does not save the rest
of this episode number three fear her I
know for a lot of people this probably
occupies the number one spot for what
they think is the worst episode that
ever and you know what not really sure I
could argue that honestly these these
top three clout they're top three and
rankings but these these three worst I
could I could make an argument for any
one of these actually being the worst
but this is where they land it for me
and fear her it's not you know it's not
good it's really weird the whole
scribbling thing and she captures she
draws it and it's captured it's like
wait how does that work and there's like
the promise of a monster of the closet
that we never really get properly and
then the whole resolution of it's just a
frightened spore thing it's a weak
resolution to a weak conflict and the
doctor gets sidelined for so much of an
instant it's so cheesy deal with him
with the Olympic torch it just I just
sat there going what am i watching
number two love and monsters now the
reason that I personally feel loving
monsters is worse than fear her is wow
it is again not good and doesn't work I
didn't personally feel like fear her was
insulting me I find love and monsters a
little bit insulting I'd towards fans
and as an audience member in general
that I get I get what it was trying to
do it was trying to have some fun with
an episode that the doctors not around
for
have some fun with ideas of fandom but I
feel like it was making fun of fans as
opposed to having fun with fans and
there's a fine line to riot I don't
think it worked in the monster I mean I
don't think I really even need to talk
that much about these the absorbed Olaf
I've talked about the thing before when
I did my worst villains list it's it's
stupid and bizarre it's a stupid concept
to which I feel like giving a pass
because I know was created by a kid for
contests but it's weirdly realized it's
a hammy performance and again I I know
that we're going for a comedic tone but
this is so over the top comedic as
opposed to when Doctor Who Comedy Works
which is you know just funny bits in
something that isn't just overtly goofy
and like so many of the things on this
list the core idea of it I actually even
kind of like let's follow the people who
the doctor is touched but now you know
they haven't seen it they're not
campaigns he's not gonna come back and
see them again
what if they met up what if they shared
experiences that's not an uninteresting
idea but this is this is this is a
painful episode but it does not hurt as
much at least for me personally as my
least favorite the one I think is the
worst the idiots Lantern now I've talked
about the villain before again when I
did my worst villains left I talked
about the wire and it's and again in
concept it's not bad it could maybe work
in the whole lose your face thing is not
a bad image it's slightly creepy but
it's just a face on a screen that goes
feed me over and over it never ever
shuts up oh god I hate that thing n if
it was just that if that was the only
thing that didn't work in this you know
what this will probably still make the
top 10 worst episodes but it would not
be a number one but the dynamic of the
family and the father this cartoonish
okay I mean he feels like a cartoon or
or an after-school special parody of a
horrible father care
you can't relate with this family
because the conflict is just so
overblown and ridiculous and it's just
it's so over the top acted on pretty
much every level the dr. Andros
themselves come off finding this they
are absolutely not the problem but
everything going on in this is just
awful the family they're trying to save
the acting is awful the father's the
worst the villain is weird in a way that
is not particularly interesting and then
executed in a way that's really annoying
and that for me is why the idiots
Lantern is the worst episode of modern
era Doctor Who but what are your
thoughts on all this what ones can you
stand what ones can you not even go back
and re-watch and you skip them when you
go through old series whatever it is
drop something down in the comments let
us talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council geeks podcast on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned